[Musique]
bonjour à tous et bienvenue à vous sur
cnews et Europe 1 bonjour à vous
François Bayrou bonjour c'est votre
grand rendez-vous ce dimanche maire de
Pau président du MoDem au commissaire
aux plans ancien ministre également de
l'éducation nationale il sera bien sûr
question dans cette émission à la veille
de la rentrée scolaire placé sous le
signe de l'interdiction de la Bayard et
bien de cette rentrée des défis qui sont
nombreux nous évoquerons également avec
vous des suites des rencontres à
Saint-Denis avec Emmanuel Macron et les
chefs de parties vous y étiez et plus
largement François Bayrou la guerre de
succession déjà ouverte vous l'avez sans
doute remarqué en vue de 2027 avec
beaucoup de monde sur la ligne de départ
pour mener ce grand rendez-vous à mes
côtés je salue mes camarades Nicolas
Barré et les échos que je suis très
heureuse de retrouver en cette année
bonjour à vous Nicolas bonjour Sonia et
bien sûr tout comme Mathieu bocotte
bonjour à vous Matthieu bonjour François
Bayrou nous ne laisserons rien passer à
affirmer le président Emmanuel Macron en
parlant des abayas et des Camille après
l'annonce de l'interdiction de ses
vêtements rendu à l'école par Gabriel
Attal nous sommes à la veille de la
rentrée scolaire est-ce que vous êtes
confiant sur l'application très concrète
justement de cette interdiction oui je
pense je pense et j'espère j'espère et
je pense que ça va bien se passer
faut comprendre que le nombre de ses
vêtements aujourd'hui et j'ai vérifié
les chiffres inférieurs de moitié
au nombre de voiles qu'il y avait dans
les temps lointain où j'étais ministre
de l'Éducation et nous avons en passant
par les règlements intérieurs des
établissements
et en prenant des médiatrices familières
des deux cultures n'avait certaines qui
ont fait beaucoup de chemin depuis
Rachida Dati était une de celle là
et donc
nous avons
réussi à cette époque là j'espère que ça
sera le cas aujourd'hui parce que je
suis en même temps pas certain que ça
soit si profondément enracinée y compris
dans les communautés
qui qui sont soit de religion soit de
culture qui amènent ses vêtements là
donc j'espère je crois et je pense que
ça devrait bien se passer comme vous
savez il y a aussi
des cours de justice administratives qui
vont qui vont fixer le droit si elles
sont saisies le droit est il y a
l'application concrète parce que
certains François bayrons ont déjà mis
en avant sur les réseaux sociaux à
hashtag fait ta rentrée en Aya il va y
avoir et beaucoup le disent une
contre-offensive les professeurs
s'enquête de tentatives de contournement
c'est cela aussi je suis je suis moins
moins sûr de ça je peux me tromper
naturellement peut y avoir ici ou là des
incidents de cet ordre mais je pense que
l'immense majorité des familles parce
que c'est surtout des familles que ça
vient l'immense majorité des familles
est acquise à l'idée que l'école s'est
trop précieux pour qu'on aille perturber
la scolarité des élèves vous dites ça
vient des familles mais il y a aussi une
part peut-être vous d'accord dentrisme
islamiste pour pousser les jeunes femmes
apporter la Baya à l'école est-ce que
vous reconnaissez cette part d'entrée
Smith
sûrement il y a des il y a des groupes
de pression et des groupes de pression
dans tous les sens il y aurait aucune
raison il n'y a aucune raison pour que
ces groupes n'existent pas là
n'est-ce pas faut comprendre une chose
je crois que on a le devoir d'entrer
dans la question fondamentale qui est
derrière tout cela
la France
que
ces jeunes filles vont habiter dans
laquelle elles vont vivre et dont elles
vont être une partie
prenante agissante et vivante
la France est pas seulement des
règlements des lois
la France est aussi une manière de vivre
des coutumes les mœurs
avant d'être une question de laïcité la
laïcité fait partie
de ce patrimoine vivant
c'est la transmission de ce patrimoine
qui compte et
l'identité d'un pays
cet ensemble de valeurs de manière
d'être de manière de vivre est
infiniment précieuse et si l'on n'y
prend pas garde alors il y a des
mouvements très violents qui se
développent qui sont des mouvements de
au fond de
le sentiment d'être assiégé
on défend le patrimoine j'ai dans un
livre il y a quelques années rappelé
qu'il y a des pays africains dans
lesquels l'identité de la communauté que
nous formons tous ensemble est inscrite
dans la Constitution
c'est légitime
de
défendre et transmettre ce patrimoine
qui est un patrimoine moral et un
patrimoine de coutume de manière de
vivre
et ce patrimoine là on doit s'y intégrer
la conduite selon laquelle tout est
question de liberté individuelle
ne me paraît pas sur le fond la seule
mais est-ce que les conditions de
l'intégration sont aujourd'hui
rassemblées les changements
démographiques sont-elles que les
porteurs apprécient de la culture des
mœurs françaises telles que vous les
indiquez sont quelquefois en minorité ou
alors c'est simplement le professeur
c'est l'institution mais c'est pas
nécessairement la population est-ce que
ce changement démographique entraîne le
changement d'identité alors
j'ai très souvent défendu l'idée que
tout était une question de proportion
lorsque vous êtes une communauté et que
vous êtes rejointes par des femmes des
hommes des familles qui sont à
l'intérieur de la communauté en nombre
équilibré alors tout se passe très bien
cet équilibreront plus aujourd'hui tout
se passe très bien lorsque l'équilibre
est rompu quel que soit les questions de
religion et de culture j'ai pris comme
exemple Mayotte
il française département français
former des familles et de la culture des
Comores
se voit rejointe et certains diront
envahi
par le nombre de comoriens qui viennent
s'installer illégalement dans le pays ce
sont c'est la même religion
est-ce que Mayotte sera l'avenir du
reste du territoire français
on vous attendez on vous attendez
donc
si vous prenez les Antilles
la présence en Guadeloupe par exemple de
nombreux de nombreuses personnes
d'origine haïtienne c'est la même
histoire
ce sont les mêmes cultures et cependant
la déstabilisation est très importante
donc c'est une question de nombre et on
pourrait dire la même chose en Guyane
donc la question
que vous citez parce que là vous citez
des exemples Mayotte mais
pour ma part je refuse de faire une
obsession de la question prise sous cet
angle là
je pense peut-être vous par exemple
il est obsédé par cela
il y a des secteurs entiers de l'opinion
il y a des courants d'opinion pour qui
cette question est devenue
obsessionnelle alors nous ne demandiez
qu'est-ce qui ne enfin où est la clé si
la société française si la France se
portait bien si elle avait l'économie
qu'elle mérite
le dynamisme économique
l'éducation oui
mais en ce moment et bien donc ce qui ne
va pas c'est que vous me demandiez
quelle est la clé de l'intégration la
clé de l'intégration c'est la santé de
la France si la France est en mauvaise
santé l'intégration se passe mal vous
avez parlé de proportion avec raison
vous parler du nombre avec raison est-ce
que cet équilibre est-ce que c'est
proportions sont respectées en France ou
est-ce que l'équilibre est rompu en
France métropolitaine je pense que le
les proportions sont respectées mais il
y a des endroits des lieux
des poches des territoires dans lesquels
en effet cette proportion est
déséquilibré donc les proportions sont
respectées sauf en certain territoire où
ils ne le sont pas oui d'autres mardi
les proportions le sont pas en plusieurs
parties si vous avez envie de tirer dans
ce sens-là vous pouvez le faire et moi
j'essaie d'avoir un langage
qui va vers les solutions plutôt que
vers l'exaspération
en fonction des professeurs parce que
c'est quand même ça le plus important
nous allons parler de démographie de
nombre de populations il y a une rentrée
qui pose qui a posé problème sous
l'angle de la Baya c'est pour ça qu'on
en parle François barose né en ce n'est
pas du tout une obsession mais pour
certains professeurs c'est même une
inquiétude il n'avait pas de comment
dire de règles claires
donc est-ce que pour vous ça veut dire
que c'est réglé parce que d'autres
estiment peut-être qu'il faut aller
jusqu'à l'uniforme justement pour ne
plus avoir ce genre de problème mais on
peut envisager la question de l'uniforme
il faut que ça vienne des établissements
eux-mêmes
je lis quelquefois on va revenir à
l'uniforme jamais eu d'uniformes dans
l'école publique française jamais il y
avait la blouse
grise pour les garçons et rose ou bleu
c'est des souvenirs d'enfance
que j'ai que j'ai dans les yeux rose ou
bleu pour les filles il y avait une
blouse
est-ce qu'on peut poser est-ce que des
établissements peuvent demander à avoir
l'uniforme ben oui bien sûr
généraliser le l'idée qu'il faut tout
généraliser est une idée que l'on doit
prendre avec précaution avec réserve
si des établissements souhaitent le
faire quelle que soit le quartier j'ai
vu des déclarations qui disaient faut
faire ça dans les quartiers politiques
de la ville comme on dit les quartiers
populaires dans la ville prioritaire de
non si on le fait il faut ouvrir cette
possibilité partout il y a pas de raison
d'ajouter à cette question une question
culturellement difficile une ségrégation
par par les résultats ou par le milieu
socioculturel dans lequel on vit on va
continuer à en parler en marque une
courte pause il y a de très très
nombreux défis évidemment à l'école en
cette veille de rentrer c'est au
ministre l'ancien ministre de
l'éducation nationale compose cette
question et puis d'autres sujets à venir
à tout de suite sur cnews et Europe 1
le grand rendez-vous c'est news
européens avec notre invité François
Bayrou il est au commissaire aux plans
il est maire de Pau et également ancien
ministre de l'éducation nationale et à
ce sujet François Bayrou il y a 22 ans
vous diffusez une circulaire interdisant
le port de sinostantatoire à l'école la
circulaire visée un peu plus de 22 ans
je crois exactement ne m'oblige pas à
rappeler
viser le foulard et la polémique avait
commencé rappelant le des 89 avec
l'affaire des collégiennes de Creil il y
avait eu énormément de polémiques à
l'époque la gauche évidemment n'avait
pas suivi cette circulaire depuis
qu'est-ce qui s'est passé est-ce que
vous dites que les choses se sont
aggravées
non je dirais pas ça vous voyez bien
la société française comme toutes les
autres sociétés
occidentales
étant perte de repères
elle se trouve profondément déstabilisée
dans sa manière de vivre et dans ces
manières de croire en quelque chose qui
les réunit qui réunit les les Français
toutes les sociétés occidentales
évidemment c'est encore plus difficile
lorsque l'on se trouve devant des chocs
culturels
des traditions culturelles des
traditions religieuses des manières
d'être des manières de vivre des
manières de qui donne le sentiment que
plus rien ne sera comme avant et plus
rien ne sera comme avant c'est un
sentiment que les êtres humains ne
peuvent pas supporter ils ont besoin de
la certitude que
ils vont pouvoir transmettre quelque
chose de ce qu'ils ont reçu à leurs
enfants
et c'est précisément sur ce point qu'il
faut les rassurer
je crois mais
vraiment à la différence de beaucoup
sans doute je crois que sur cette
question de
d'immigration quel que soit les
générations si les personnes travaillent
ça renvoie à l'économie
si les personnes maîtrisent la langue
française celle qui ne l'a parlait pas
et celle qui la parle de ou qui devrait
la parler de naissance si j'ose dire un
grand nombre des violences
urbaines comme on dit tous ceux qui ont
regardé ça savent qu'il y a des
adolescents ou des jeunes adultes qui
sont incapables de traduire ce qu'il
ressentent et donc ça fait des violences
c'est c'est de la psychologie
élémentaire d'une société dans laquelle
on vit si il y a la compréhension que
les manières de vivre d'un pays font
partie intégrante de et pourquoi n'y
a-t-il pas cette compréhension
justement et une parenthèse vous dites
tradition en parlant peut-être de la
Baya mais est-ce une tradition ou est-ce
une offensive islamiste
c'est ce sont des phénomènes
de bord de limite bien sûr qu'il y en a
le
très grand travail que nous avons à
faire c'est que tout le monde dans la
société française comprenne et mesure
que nous avons un patrimoine que ce
patrimoine est fait partie intégrante de
notre avenir
est-ce qu'il est attaqué ce patrimoine
parce que ce qui n'est pas un phénomène
de bord par rapport à l'époque où vous
étiez ministre de l'éducation nationale
c'est que le nombre d'atteintes à la
laïcité augmente sous ce que dit
aujourd'hui le ministère de l'Éducation
nationale il y a davantage d'attentes à
la laïcité dans les établissements
comment on lutte contre toujours alors
peut-être
un professeur qui ne va pas faire sa
rentrée cette année
et de ce point de vue là je trouve
souvent que
son souvenir est trop oublié
et que
ce jeune homme
a perdu la vie simplement parce qu'il
croyait
aux valeurs qu'il enseignait il est
oublié peut-être aussi parce que son nom
n'est pas accolé à certains collèges
parce que on le refuse l'idée vous
l'avez noté quand on dit on pourrait
nommer au lycée Samuel Paty la réaction
c'est pas le nôtre on a peur d'être
attaqué c'est une peur pour sa propre
vie oui c'est vrai ce que vous dites
permettez-moi de dire que nous n'y
arriverons pas
si nous présentons les choses comme
perpétuellement et gravissimement
exacerbé est-ce qu'il y a des attaques
bien sûr qu'il y en a dans tous les sens
est-ce qu'il y a des
incompréhensions brutales bien sûr qu'il
y en a dans tous les sens mais je ne
crois pas que la présence de l'islam en
France soit une présence
profondément agressive il y a des
éléments d'agression mais on vit très
bien je suis maire d'une ville dans
laquelle forcément il y a des quartiers
comme on dit et il y a des communautés
différentes il y a des dizaines de
nationalités dans ces quartiers là bien
sûr
mais cependant on arrive à vivre
ensemble alors c'est pas facile
il y a
90% des musulmans français qui sont bien
intégrés à la société française
et islamisme puisque vous parlez
d'obsession certains ont cette obsession
et puis qu'avez-vous pensé monsieur
Bayero de la réaction d'une partie de la
gauche puisque là vous appelez à
transcender toutes ces questions mais
une partie de la gauche et la France
insoumise a quand même parlé de
stigmatisation et même d'islamophobie de
la part du ministre Gabriel tal vous
pensez qu'il est possible de composer je
pense qu'une partie de la gauche est
obsédé par l'idée que c'est dans ces
quartiers et dans la minorité la plus
déstabilisée de ces quartiers qu'elle va
trouver son futur électorat
cette partie de la gauche a une
stratégie qui est d'identifier ces
quartiers au lumppen pour les Terriens
comme on disait dans les temps
révolutionnaires ou marxiste d'autres
fois et que c'est là qu'ils vont trouver
leur réserves électorale je suis
persuadé qu'il se trompe mais vous voyez
bien si vous regardez
l'échiquier politique
évidemment de même qu'il y a
symétriquement sur l'autre côté c'est à
dire du côté de des extrêmes droites
parce qu'il y a plusieurs extrêmes
droites il y a une partie de cela qui se
disent que là et le sujet qui va les
porter au pouvoir et moi je pense que
notre devoir alors je parle là je ne
parle pas de d'opportunités
[Musique]
de plus de vote dans des circonstances
électorales notre devoir
c'est de faire en sorte que la
compréhension réciproque l'emporte sur
l'exaspération réciproque et pour ça il
faut des politiques claires vous dites
c'est le cas avec Gabriel Attal
reconnaissait monsieur barroc avec
l'ancien ministre de l'Éducation papa
N'Diaye qui avait dit qu'il n'allait pas
aller jusqu'à mesurer la longueur des
robes on a de quoi être perdu est-ce que
le président est sur la ligne on a
compris aujourd'hui qu'il est sur la
ligne de en tous les 400 ministre de
l'éducation mais comment on peut passer
de Papen diète de Gabriel Attal sur
cette question comme ça en quelques
semaines excusez-moi j'ai aucune envie
de de stigmatiser des ministres de
l'éducation successive
d'extrême gauche complaisant avec le
communautarisme je ne crois aucun des
trois
c'est un homme que j'ai rencontré que
j'ai écouté je pense qu'il était
profondément républicain qu'il est
profondément républicain parce qu'il est
en fonction maintenant dans d'autres
fonctions et j'ai aucune envie de de
faire monter cette nuit
est-ce que la société française soutient
suffisamment les professeurs pas sur
cette question jolie pirouette pour se
répondre
pas sur cette question seulement mais
sur leur métier sur son exercice
regardez monsieur
c'est la ligne du président la ligne du
président qui semble quand même à
travers ces deux ministres radicalement
sensiblement opposé disons dans leur
ligne vis-à-vis de la laïcité je pense
que la ligne du président de la
République est très claire il avait
exprimé en nommant Jean-Michel Blanquer
comme son premier ministre de
l'Éducation oui Jean-Michel Blanquer a
fait deux années
vraiment excellentes
non il y a chaque fois il y a des
nuances des ministres de l'éducation qui
m'avait précédé était pas exactement
comme moi et ce qui m'ont succédé était
pas exactement comme moi non plus de
disons qu'il y a une ligne
Chevènement Bayrou
Blanquer qui est qui est une ligne très
très centré sur les fondamentaux de
l'école est participé et sur les
fondamentaux et le savoir je crois que
oui
je crois
j'en ai parlé beaucoup avec lui je pense
que
c'est quelqu'un qui était sensible aux
sentiments des minorités
et comment quand vous êtes enseignant ne
pas être sensible aux minorités
moi je veux je veux dire que
il y a des réflexes qui consiste à
penser perpétuellement que les
professeurs ne travaillent pas assez
on entend ça tout le temps que il
suffirait moi je voudrais que ceux qui
les critiquent comme ça à y passer 15
jours devant une classe
qu'il mesure réellement ce qu'est le
travail d'investissement préparation des
cours
maîtrise des classes quand ça commence à
bouger
correction des copies
conseils de classe réception des parents
agressions des parents assez souvent je
voudrais que tous ceux qui les
critiquent
aillent ce se confronter à la réalité
comme elle explique probablement aussi
en partie la pénurie justement de ces
enseignants à la rentrée on va continuer
d'en parler en marquer une courte pause
et puis je vais dire la politique pure
vous avez participé en rencontre de
Saint-Denis avec em Macron et les chefs
de partir tout a été dit vous allez nous
dire ce qui s'est vraiment passé oui
parce que j'y étais donc je sais plus
en direct bien sûr merci de votre
fidélité en ce dimanche pour le grand
rendez-vous avec notre invité François
bayraud qui était présent au fameuses
rencontres de Saint-Denis alors c'est
vrai que c'est rencontre entre Emmanuel
Macron
le premier métier de
l'école la première mission sa vocation
c'est la transmission de la culture
générale la transmission des
connaissances d'un d'un patrimoine de
connaissances et de maîtrise des
fondamentaux et on croit que ces
distinctes de
de l'éducation civique du vivre ensemble
c'est la même chose mais est-ce que
cette mission est aussi bien assurée
qu'il y a une génération ou deux
générations non c'est ça la vraie
question
non j'ai écrit il y a très longtemps un
livre qui s'appelait la décennie des
malapris donc vous viendrez peut-être
oui je pense que que nous avons des
problèmes de transmission que ces
problèmes de transmission des
connaissances et des fondamentaux elles
se pose y compris techniquement
pédagogiquement en termes nouveaux qu'on
ne sait pas traité on vient souvent avec
des idéologies
qui sont à côté de la plaque parce
qu'elles ne biologique le président a
dénoncé dans le dans une interview
longue interview point le pédagogisme
est-ce que le pédagogiste justement est
une de ces idéologies que tout est dans
la pédagogie et une pédagogie définie
d'en haut
je suis pour un travail sur la pédagogie
partant de la base des réussites dans
chaque classe on a tous connu des profs
formidables simplement personne ne sait
qu'ils existent l'administration ne les
repère pas et donc il est impossible de
les ayant pas repéré de répandre leur
savoir-faire de suivre les méthodes
qu'ils ont élaborées eux-mêmes
et donc je crois que c'est cela que le
Président de la République appelle le
pédagogiste un parti pris de
pédagogie définie d'en haut et définit
très souvent vous me dites que la
priorité et donc c'est d'apprendre à
lire à écrire raconter me pardonner moi
ça peut paraître évident mais c'est
mieux en le disant
c'est d'apprendre la lecture la maîtrise
de l'écrit la maîtrise de l'oral la
capacité d'expression
et et puis aussi un certain nombre de
règles de la vie c'est beaucoup et peu à
la fois si vous me permettez me dire
normalement on a quand on se représente
l'idée du petit enfant français à
l'école des hussard noir de la
République on espérait davantage que la
prenne simplement à s'exprimer
correctement on espérait qu'on lui
transmette une culture littéraire
historique mais vous êtes en train de
découper en tranches quelque chose qui
ne doit pas être découpé la culture
générale ne se divise pas quand le
président parle ou rappelle parce que
c'est déjà sans doute ça a été rappelé
dans d'autres programmes
y compris sous ma responsabilité que
l'histoire ça doit s'apprendre avec des
repères dans le temps
avec
une chronologie et de savoir que
Louis XIV c'est pas le 14e siècle et que
Louis XV c'est pas le 15e siècle et que
que simplement on arrive à se repérer
dans les générations tous ces temps-là
sont proches de nous mais les élèves
n'en n'ont aucune idée pour eux c'est
très très loin je suis persuadé que on
peut trouver des terrains d'entente en
partant de la pratique des profs qui
réussissent et qui sont nombreux et qui
sont désespérés souvent parce que
personne ne voit les efforts qu'ils font
et au contraire on continue à les
accabrer de soupçons que ils travaillent
pas que il devrait faire beaucoup plus
d'heures qu'ils ne font ce qui ce qui
n'est pas un retour au fondamentaux
au moment où certains parlent du fait
qu'il faille aussi intégrer plus
d'éducation
sexuelle et d'autres choses vous vous
dites
la priorité ce que c'est bien ça je
pense que la priorité
l'instruction
la transmission la transmission des
connaissances et la transmission des
langages des méthodes des pratiques
c'est ça l'essentiel et je crois qu'on
peut y arriver j'ai une grande
différence avec la plupart de ceux qui
s'expriment sur l'éducation moi en
attendant beaucoup de personnalités
s'expriment encore hier à la Une je
pense qu'on peut y arriver je pense que
les progrès sont apportés de la main en
attendant les ministres passent et le
niveau d'éducation baisse donc comment
se fait-il qu'on n'y arrive pas parce
que personne ne prend la mesure du défi
j'espère que le président j'espère si
exactement vous avez cité c'est vous
avez cité ces propos j'étais très
content qu'ils disent
qu'au fond l'éducation appartenait
désormais au domaine réservé on dirait
que c'est le premier prof de France qui
s'exprime que l'éducation et je trouve
ça vraiment très bien
le président de la République c'est
quelqu'un qui doit se sentir en charge
de l'essentiel il doit penser l'avenir
j'espère l'y aider avec le plan à 20 ans
ou 30 ans 10 ans 20 ans 30 ans il doit
penser les problèmes de défense les
problèmes de choc géopolitique des
grandes des grandes entités et il doit
penser l'éducation parce que c'est la
même chose mais est-ce que c'est pas la
possibilité même de l'enseignement qui
est compromise aujourd'hui je m'explique
un professeur dans sa classe des élèves
très souvent turbulants qui ne
respectent plus spontanément l'autorité
qui ont été écrasés c'est-à-dire une
bonne partie de leur attention et
centrée sur les différents écrans qui
meubles leur vie et qui d'autre quelque
chose de ce que la parole de cet homme
ou de cette femme vaut autant que celle
de toutes les autres sources d'influence
possible est-ce que la possibilité même
aussi l'enseignement aujourd'hui n'est
pas fragilisé elle est fragilisée et
c'est là une raison précisément pour
lequel il faut qu'on reprenne les choses
en main je prends les deux questions que
vous indiquez les écrans dans la Silicon
Valley comme vous savez comme
quelques-uns savent les enfants de ceux
qui sont les praticiens et les
inventeurs de l'Internet ils sont dans
des écoles où les écrans sont interdits
pourquoi parce qu'ils ont compris
quelque chose l'écran il vous transmet
des informations sans que vous ayez des
forts à faire vous voulez dire qu'ils
appelaient
alors qu'on fait la promotions
par exemple
entre autres
donc ça c'est la première chose
deuxièmement
est-ce qu'on peut se contenter de
baisser les bras quand des élèves sont
en situation de rupture avec l'éducation
je ne le crois pas j'ai défendu et je
suis prêt à défendre encore l'idée que
j'avais appelé le collège hors les murs
c'est à dire
on ne peut pas accepter que tu restes
dans la classe pour mettre le bazar dans
la classe on va te proposer une démarche
extérieure à l'établissement et puis tu
reviendras après quand on aura réussi à
te transmettre
voilà quand on a été ministre de
l'éducation
mais je m'adresse à l'ancien ministre
je vais vous demander la liste si vous
mis encourager les rencontres de
Saint-Denis vous y avez participé avec
Emmanuel Macron et les différents chefs
de parties représentés au Parlement
c'est peu de dire monsieur Berrou
qu'elles ont été diversesment appréciées
il y a le porte-parole du gouvernement
qui parle de rencontre historique et
puis vous avez l'opposition notamment à
gauche tout ça pour ça la montagne a
couché d'une souris mais vous qu'est-ce
que vous diriez vous y étiez je crois
pas que votre compte rendu soit
alors je vais vous faire le mien d'abord
j'ai beaucoup aimé l'expression d'un
grand journal du soir qui a dit la nuit
du 30 août par référence à la nuit du 4
août
dans lequel on a aboli les privilèges là
on est entré enfin de plain-pied dans
une question centrale qu'on ne traite
pas depuis des décennies et qui est
celle de la gestion du pluralisme dans
un pays comme la France
on continue à vivre avec l'idée que il y
a deux blocs les pour et les contre
or la France ça n'est plus ça
approfondément changé
le
le bip artisme
est mort enterré j'espère et on a bien
fait de le faire et j'ai militait
beaucoup pour ça et nous sommes
maintenant devant l'obligation de
reconnaître que la société française a
des sensibilités différentes obligations
parce que nous avons président sans
majorité absolue qui n'a pas le choix
que de faire des compromis
il se trouve que j'ai au cours des
années beaucoup parlé de ce sujet avec
lui et que toutes les tentatives qu'il a
faites le grand débat le conseil de la
refondation
et cette initiative de Saint-Denis
toutes ces initiatives allaient dans le
même croissance essayez de saisir le
pouls vivant du pays pour que les gens
de la base qui ont des des
identités politiques différentes
ébauchés jamais les mêmes puissent
reconnaître dans le rapport avec les
pouvoirs
toutes les institutions non pas du tout
vous vous trompez complètement ah bon
excusez-moi il est il a jamais été
question et il ne sera jamais question
que ces initiatives remplacent le
Parlement sa délibération c'est ses
votes et l'établissement de la loi
de poser la question quand même
vous voulez qu'on s'arrête une seconde
sur la réforme
des retraites est une chance manquée je
l'ai dit tout au long de cette pourquoi
parce qu'on n'a pas fourni aux citoyens
les informations sur la réalité des et
notamment très en amont
ces informations
officielles des retraites ont passé des
années à dire qu'en fait il y avait pas
de problème que c'était à l'équilibre
même ils étaient que c'était
excédentaire que le régime des retraites
en France était excédentaire et toutes
les oppositions se sont branchées
évidemment sur ces sur ces informations
là même s'il soupçonnaient qu'elles
étaient biaisées mais comment
voulez-vous que le l'esprit public
progresse
se forme une idée si on lui donne pas
les vrais plus de temps pour cela est-ce
que cette phrase vraiment qui a été
rapportée qui a fait écoulé beaucoup
d'encre est-ce qu'Emmanuel Macron là la
dite peut-être devant vous c'était une
réponse à une question de Jordan
Bardella sur le septennat unique
Emmanuel Macron aurait dit ou a dit de
ne pas pouvoir être réélu est une
funeste pardonnez-moi connerie c'est le
cas ça a été prononcé moi j'ai pas
entendu ça
vous savez il y a des il y a des souris
il y a des échanges c'était une table
comme celle-ci mais comme vous êtes très
attentif à tout oui je suis attentif
mais ça correspond à l'état d'esprit du
président
tous les présidents j'imagine se disent
que toute l'imitation temporaire à la
temporelle à leur mandat
est en effet pas la meilleure idée
possible mais c'est comme ça mais c'est
très bien que dans les sociétés
politiques ont fixe des termes de cet
ordre donc vous ne regrettez pas que
Emmanuel Macron ne puisse pas se
représenter en 2000 je pense qu'il sait
il a intégré depuis le premier jour que
c'était dix ans et pas un jour de plus
sauf à être réélu après dans une autre
élection donc et je ne crois pas moi que
que cet homme jeune quittera la scène
politique comme ça pour aller comme on
dit faire des affaires je crois pas ça
une seconde il me l'a jamais dit
qu'est-ce que vous qu'est-ce que vous
voulez dire par là que le jour il quitte
le pouvoir il pense déjà de quelle
manière y revenir le jour où il quittera
le pouvoir il restera un leader
démocratique français et européen en
attendant sa succession est ouverte
c'est même une guerre une bataille vous
choisirez votre mot on va en parler
peut-être faites-vous partie de ceux qui
sont sur la ligne de départ Monsieur
Bayrou à tout de suite sur ces news et
repas
le grand rendez-vous sur cnews et Europe
1 nous parlions des suites des
rencontres à Saint-Denis entre le
Président de la République et les
différents chefs de parties représentés
au Parlement on va vous laisser raconter
de l'intérieur ce qui s'est passé
François Bayonne une question parce que
le RN exige un référendum sur
l'émigration la droite le souhaite
également et vous
on ne peut faire un référendum que sur
une loi
pouvez pas poser une question en disant
est-ce que vous êtes pour ou contre
la pluie
l'inflation non mais bien sûr mais il y
aurait un texte et donc et donc un texte
encore faut-il que le texte soit élaboré
je vous rappelle que ce texte c'est une
initiative qui doit être prise par le
gouvernement ou par les deux assemblées
le président de la République qui décide
interroger les Français sur une question
tout à fait légitime
je suis prudent en face des questions
qui déchaînent les passions il faudrait
poser des questions
que ce sont des questions qui sont
explosives et j'ai pas envie
d'exposition trouve un texte
équilibré pourquoi pas mais la tentation
sera grande à cet instant-là de
transformer le référendum en plébiscite
en plébiscite d'approbation minoritaire
et de désapprobation majoritaire
pourquoi on a du mal à interroger les
Français sur un sujet aussi important
parce que on a pris l'habitude de lier
le référendum au sort du président de la
République et que c'est donc une
question pour ou contre le président de
la République et au lieu de traiter du
fond j'espère qu'on trouvera des sujets
sur lesquels je pense par exemple je
l'ai dit je crois à votre micro que les
retraites auraient fait un remarquable
sujet de référendum à condition que tout
le monde
ait été associés à l'information les
citoyens chez eux et que tout le monde
ait été associé à la réflexion sur
l'élaboration des textes donc je
comprends pour vous la question des
retraites c'était moins explosive que
l'immigration pourquoi l'immigration
vous savez bien c'est passionnelle c'est
épidermique c'est ça fait appel à des
à des choses très profondes et très
explosive que redoutez-vous plus
exactement et c'était très drôle vous
parliez de ces rencontres de Saint-Denis
de cette nuit du 30 août c'était très
drôle parce que
à un moment alors le cadre d'abord ces
gens là ne s'étaient jamais rencontré
j'avais jamais parlé ensemble
Bardella
moi-même Édouard Philippe et Stéphane
séjourné et Éric Ciotti les chefs de
partie qui ont des élus au Parlement des
courants profonds de la nation c'est
quand même quelque chose qui mérite
qu'on s'y arrête c'est femme et ses
hommes là c'était jamais rencontré
n'avait jamais parlé ensemble et c'est
le président de la République il est
réuni pour qu'ils échangent et c'est
magnifique on a on a tout le temps
peut-être un jour on constatera il n'y a
pas eu de résultats
et c'est trop rapide quand on est
journaliste de dire mais alors qu'est-ce
que vous avez décidé c'est un très grand
progrès
que le Président de la République au
lieu d'être
caricaturé en chef de clan
apparaissent comme ce qu'il doit être
c'est à dire le fédérateur du pays et ce
président qui ne croyait pas dans les
corps intermédiaires mais les partis
politiques sont des corps intermédiaires
dont il faut tenir compte les autres
aussi les syndicats aussi pas imaginable
qui est une
convention sociale sans que les
syndicats y soient forcément associés
donc mais c'est inédit pour vous c'est
inédit l'événement lui-même est au
progrès l'événement dit quelque chose de
très profond il y a pas eu la politique
de la chaise vide ça vous l'avez
souligné 12 heures de temps et avec des
zones d'accord incroyables sur la
politique étrangère incroyable
on espère que ces domaines fassent
consensus
sur l'Ukraine par exemple vous auriez eu
des confrontations extrêmement
chacun des intervenants a dit on est
d'accord mais ce matin les Français qui
nous regardent monsieur Baillot je suis
obligé d'en parler quand même les prix
de des fournitures scolaires les prix à
la pompe tous ces sujets
ne se traiteront pas si nous ne sommes
pas capables d'entrer dans une nouvelle
période démocratique autrement ça
cassera après la nuit du 30 août il y
aura un avant et après la démocratie est
mise en cause partout sur la planète
partout il y a des gens qui disent
écouter c'est absolument pas efficace
votre truc qu'est-ce que ça veut dire de
parler si longtemps vous au bout de 12
heures vous dites mais vous avez pas
obtenu les résultats on est entré dans
une démarche on est entré dans une
démarche inédite c'est la première fois
dans l'histoire
c'était totalement inattendu y compris
des participants qui avaient dit on
viendra pas où on s'en ira si on doit
manger enfin des des trucs de cet ordre
qui était qui était un peu caricaturaux
et tout le monde a participé à cet
échange et d'ailleurs vous aurez noté
que même de la part des oppositions les
réactions sont modérées équilibrées donc
vous souhaitez qu'il recommence
cet exercice
qu'on entre dans le profond des choses
par exemple on a beaucoup évoqué les
institutions le fonctionnement de la
démocratie les référendum
quelle précaution pour qu'un référendum
soit utile ben ça nécessite beaucoup de
travail comment toutes les formations
autour de la table si je me suis pas
trompé toutes ont considéré que l'idée
d'une loi électorale juste qui
permettent de représenter le pluralisme
était très importantes toutes les
formations non avant on n'aurait pas eu
ce genre de participants qui avaient
peut-être d'autres idées dans la tête
permettez-moi de le dire peut-être un
ancien Premier ministre prénommé Édouard
Philippe vous allez voir dans un sondage
qui est en pôle position pour
représenter la droite en 2027 quand vous
l'avez face à vous que vous le regardez
vous dites c'est potentiellement
peut-être le prochain président je
trouve que quand j'ai vu cette nouvelle
ce matin je me suis dit on va
recommencer ça les sondages sans aucune
exception sur les dernières élections
présidentielles se sont trompés
chaque fois gravissimement et on
comprend très bien pourquoi
c'est quelqu'un d'estimable qui a exécé
qui a été premier ministre et qui donne
eu une idée il allait être de ce qu'est
un responsable politique il a l'air vous
dites il est estimable mais ce qu'il a
l'étoffe d'un chef d'État je peux en
prononcer sur ces sujets la question
c'est est-ce que est-ce que les futurs
candidats ce qui participeront à ce
débat de l'élection présidentielle
est-ce qu'ils seront comprendre le pays
parler de vous remarquer qu'il se
manifeste en ce moment je vais employer
je vais employer un mot le maire lui
parler de son âme
parler bien sûr elle ne cesse jamais la
course parler au pays de son âme de ce
qu'il est à chaque famille de ses
raisons de vivre s'il vous plaît 10
secondes est-ce que vous vous parlez à
l'âme de ce pays est-ce que vous serez
le candidat qui va parler à l'âme de ce
pays vous voyez vous c'est un slogan
presque
et vous c'est l'élection majeure et
principale alors j'ai lu dans un
commentaire que il y avait l'usure du
temps vous n'excluez et moi je crois
que c'est exactement le contraire
le temps et l'expérience vous n'excluez
pas de vous présenter dans la dans
lesquelles nous allons entrer cette
une chance
on a on a vécu on a vécu
des périodes mais rarement des périodes
aussi difficiles que maintenant et après
dans quatre ans on verra bien tout est
ouvert vous ne savez pas si vous serez
là encore non nous ne savons pas à titre
individuel si nous serons encore là et
nous ne savons pas quels seront les
secousses auxquelles notre pays va être
soumis mais sachons simplement que si on
croit des choses profondes et ce n'est
capable de les partager avec les
citoyens au féminin et au masculin
français alors probablement on touchera
de plus près ce que une élection comme
celle-là peut avoir
profondes n'est-ce pas et qui va faire
réfléchir nos auditeurs et
téléspectateurs merci François